y'all had fun at the wrap party though
what's happening what's happening there
I saw I saw well one I saw photo and I
saw some footage we're gonna get to well
what was that a great rap party and then
they pull this up on stage for karaoke
and we were singing some new kids on the
block because who does not why not and
and then they surprised us and we sang
the fuller house theme song cuz everyone
knows it and that was really fun
I would totally sing along I know the
whole thing I don't even know all the
way kind of do you had an unexpected
audience I hear with karaoke okay so the
embarrassing part is that karaoke
Candice doesn't come out very often it's
like once in a while
Carrie cuz fun I know but I don't do
that publicly very often okay
rapping Lots baby got back yeah yes so
wait what was the unexpected audience
apart was that like I got a message the
next morning from Jodie Sweetin she
texted me a video message and she was
like hey Candace
I'm outside and I bet you didn't know
but your video right now is being
broadcast to all of Hollywood and
Highland now for those of you that don't
know pins you're at that or when I was
that bully a Lucky Strike that's all in
there and Hollywood and Highland is like
Times Square yes so my karaoke version
like for everyone to see that version of
twerk it's just a little a little so do
you like karaoke I love karaoke cuz
people think that singers are like over
but I love I love karaoke but the weird
it's weird if you're a singer and you go
in and you sing your own song you know
what I mean look like an idiot but do
people ever go like hey that guy's
pretty good he sounds just like him like
they don't they don't get it that
happened to me once I was karaoke with
Reba and then she got up on stage we
stay together obviously they recognized
her and but they kept going she looks
like Kelly Clarkson and then Reba got on
stage and it was really awesome we had
had some drinks I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this